continuamos nos quedamos estamos
observando la hoja de balance del banco
a key y vimos que de lado los activos
tenían bonos del gobierno bonos
corporativos triple-a hipotecas
comerciales y esta es la cosa que quería
remarcar que también tenía 4 billones de
pesos de obligaciones de deuda
colateralizada y luego hablé un poco
acerca de qué son estos cede os tengo
varios vídeos que lo explican con mucho
más detalle y de cómo probablemente
provocaron la burbuja inmobiliaria y
luego tenemos un poco de efectivo ahora
damos del lado de los pasivos pues tiene
un montón de deudas con un montón de
personas si fuera un banco comercial
como banamex bancomer entonces uno de
estos pasivos serían los depósitos de la
gente que guarda su dinero en el banco
pero lo vamos a asumir eso este podría
ser cualquier tipo de banco de hecho
podría ser cualquier tipo de institución
financiera no tiene que ser un banco
podría ser la hoja de balance de un
fondo de cobertura o una firma de
capital privado o cualquier tipo de
institución financiera regresando al
ejemplo dijimos y lo vimos en el primer
vídeo
en el vídeo de la hoja de balance que si
toman los activos y le restan los
pasivos es decir tomas todo lo que
tienes y le quitas lo que debes
te quedas con lo que realmente es tuyo y
a eso le llamamos el capital si eres una
empresa que cotiza en la bolsa bueno de
hecho solo tienes que ser una empresa
esto se llama el patrimonio neto o los
fondos propios y las personas que tienen
una inversión en la compañía o que
tienen acciones de la empresa comparten
este pedazo y esto es algo muy
importante y siento que las personas no
ponen mucha atención en este detalle hay
dos nociones está tu valor libro del
capital y ese es el valor del capital
que sale de la hoja de balance
entonces si supones que todos estos
números están correctos y hay que pensar
qué es lo que significa eso de que los
números estén correctos y supones que
todos estos números también están
correctos entonces este número es el
valor libro de tu capital y si en este
ejemplo decimos que el banco a es una
empresa pública y tiene 500 mil millones
de acciones si dividimos los tres
millones entre los 500 mil millones de
acciones
que el valor libro por acción de la
empresa vale 6 pesos y eso significa que
si todos estos números están correctos
entonces cada acción de la compañía vale
exactamente 6 pesos exactamente 6 pesos
por acción ahora puedes decirme que esto
no tiene el más mínimo sentido que todos
sabemos que el mercado valores es muy
arriesgado especialmente los valores
bancarios que suben y bajan y banda de
derecha a izquierda y como puedes
decirme que con solo ver la hoja de
balance podemos calcular exactamente
cuál es el valor neto de cada acción y
bueno esa es una distinción muy
importante déjame borrar esto porque es
simplemente una distracción y bueno tal
vez quieras ver el vídeo sobre títulos
con garantía hipotecaria u obligaciones
de deuda colateralizada si necesitas un
repaso de allí entonces qué es lo que yo
quiero decir cuando te digo que puedes
ver la hoja de balance de un banco y si
crees en lo que está escrito allí
entonces puedes calcular el valor libro
de cada acción entonces porque las
acciones fluctúan tan salvajemente de
izquierda a derecha
pues de hecho es muy interesante o sea
te dice lo que el mercado piensa sobre
esta hoja de balance a ver déjame
relleno esto eran 26 billones de activos
y 23 billones de pasivos dejándonos un
capital de 3 billones y un valor libro
de 6 pesos por acción
entonces digamos que vas a la sección de
finanzas de yahoo y buscas el banco y
digamos que su precio del mercado es no
sé digamos que son 12 pesos por acción
aunque hay 12 pesos por acción
entonces qué está pasando aquí el valor
libro es de 6 pesos pero el mercado está
diciendo no no no no no no nosotros
estamos dispuestos a pagar 12 pesos por
cada una de estas acciones y un punto
importante cuando compras una acción en
el mercado de valores
ese dinero no solo estás dando a la
compañía la compañía obtiene dinero en
un principio al vender acciones y eso
generalmente se hace en una oferta
pública inicial ellos venden las
acciones directamente al público y ese
dinero si va directamente a la empresa y
hablaremos de eso más adelante pero el
99% de las veces cuando compras una
acción el dinero no se lo queda a la
compañía sino la persona que tenía la
acción también por eso se le llama el
mercado secundario entonces es un montón
de personas negociando el precio de una
acción y la única razón por la que ese
precio le puede importar a la compañía
sería si la compañía quisiera recaudar
más dinero en un futuro digamos que en
acción a los 12 pesos hoy y yo compré
una no sé tal vez la compre a ti pero
bueno no se la compré a la compañía
y le dice a la compañía que si
necesitara dinero entonces podría vender
acciones a un precio cercano a 12 pesos
y eso también le dice a alguien que
quiera comprar la compañía que tal vez
se ofreciera una especie de prima a 12
pesos por acción entonces podría comprar
todas las existencias ahorita que lo
pienso deberías hacer vídeos sobre todos
estos conceptos pero bueno el mercado
está dando un precio de 12 pesos por
acción es decir la persona que está
pagando 12 pesos por acción está
suponiendo que esto está subestimado y
si el valor el libro está subestimado
eso quiere decir que los activos están
subestimados o los pasivos están sobre
estimados la mayoría de las veces los
pasivos son muy fáciles de calcular
precisamente tal vez algunas tensiones o
pasivos derivados de litigios en trámite
sean difíciles de calcular pero la
mayoría de las veces puedes ver la hoja
de balance y decir ok este es el dinero
que deben lo que generalmente es más
difícil de calcular son los activos
entonces con esta hoja de balance diría
que hay un valor libro de seis pesos por
acción pero el mercado está dispuesto a
las doce entonces estos activos están
siendo subestimados de alguna forma o la
compañía tiene algunos activos que por
alguna razón no aparecen en la hoja de
balance tal vez porque son intangibles o
son algún tipo de poder adquisitivo que
no se puede reflejar aquí creo que
cuando hice los vídeos de la hoja de
balance dije que no se podía cuantificar
el carisma o la buena apariencia y tal
vez por eso tengo más activos de lo que
mi hoja de balance puede predecir pues
es la misma noción pero a nivel y
compañía tal vez si ésta fuera la hoja
de balance de banamex el valor libro es
de 6 pesos por acción pero el mercado
está dispuesto a pagar 12 pesos por
acción porque tiene el 'chicharito' en
sus anuncios y eso le da popularidad que
es equivalente al carisma y dicen sólo
por su popularidad y por su marca ellos
pueden hacer más con los activos que
tengan y entonces estoy dispuesto a
pagar una prima a su valor libro y sea
cierto no eso de que por su popularidad
pueden hacer más pues es difícil de
discutir o sea también está el caso
o la que tiene una marca muy pero muy
fuerte y donde esa marca y esa receta
secreta realmente son el valor de la
firma y no está en su hoja de balance
con un banco yo sería mucho más
escéptica a la hora de pagar un múltiplo
considerable del valor libro de una
acción este es el precio de mercado yo
me lo pensaría dos veces antes de pagar
el doble del valor libro pero de hecho
no es difícil encontrar compañías cuyo
precio de mercado es mucho más grande
que el valor libro y bueno eso es lo que
significa lo que el mercado está
diciendo si están pagando 12 pesos por
acción por algo que tiene un valor libro
de 6 pesos por acción o tal vez alguno
de estos activos vale más tal vez aquí
en los libros hay una propiedad justo en
el centro del df que compraron hace 50
años y en los libros le pusieron un
valor de 50 centavos pero los dueños de
las acciones dice no no eso vale más de
un millón de pesos otra cosa importante
es que si el mercado está pagando 12
pesos por acción
cuál es la capitalización de mercado
es decir cuánto estima el mercado que
vale el capital de la compañía para
obtener la capitalización de mercado
tomas el precio del mercado lo
multiplicas por la cantidad acciones
aunque hay entonces son 12 por 500 mil
millones
y entonces obtenemos 6 billones de pesos
entonces si hoy se están comprando
acciones a 12 pesos eso dice que el
mercado o al menos las personas que
están comprando estas acciones y voy a
hacer una serie de vídeos explicando
cómo se asignan los precios eso
significa que ellos creen que este
capital no vale 3 billones sino que vale
6 billones ya sea por la marca la
fórmula secreta o algunos tus activos
está siendo subestimado a algo por ahí
bueno esta es la situación donde el
precio de mercado es más grande que el
valor libro pero qué pasa si digamos el
día de hoy el precio del mercado está a
3 pesos por acción
ok 3 pesos por acción y tenemos 500 mil
millones de acciones
entonces la capitalización de mercado es
3 por medio billón que son 500 mil
millones
ya que es 1.5 billones esto es lo que el
mercado estima que vale el capital de la
compañía entonces el mercado dice a mí
no importa que el banco a diga que tiene
3 billones de pesos que sus activos
menos pasivos son tres billones nosotros
no se las compramos nosotros creemos que
esto sólo vale 1.5 billones y eso es
probablemente porque creen que una de
estas cosas del lado izquierdo uno de
estos activos valen menos de lo que el
banco dice que vale
también también podría hacer que uno de
estos pasivos valiera más podría haber
un pasivo derivado de cuestiones
ambientales que se esté subestimando
pero no nos vamos a meter en eso eso lo
vamos a ver en otro vídeo cuando la
capitalización del mercado es menor que
el valor libro del capital
el mercado está diciendo ya que echamos
tu blog algo aquí no nos huele bien algo
aquí no vale lo que tú estás diciendo
que vale nos vemos en el próximo vídeo
como siempre